[Musique]
adrien velits à adrien velits la
création du monde là au commencement
commencement il n'y avait rien puisqu'il
n'y avait pas de monde
le seigneur le créateur qui qui portait
un nom usurpé puisque il n'avait jamais
rien créé deidda rougissante son
inaction de créer le monde
oui j'entends bien qu'il avait déjà créé
quelques petites choses lui qui était
sans importance puisque le monde
n'existait pas encore
c'étaient des choses qui étaient comme
si elle n'avait jamais existé en quelque
sorte a donc il décida de créer le monde
mais comme c'était une personne d'ordre
il se garda bien de le créer dans le
désordre et laventure il préféra comme
disait gambetta sérier les questions et
se donne à huit jours pour mener à bien
les opérations
le premier jour dieu créa le tout paris
le bottin mondain l'annuaire des
châteaux et l'officiel des spectacles
surtout la liste des rues de paris par
ordre alphabétique
le deuxième jour dieu créa les jours de
réception les dîners en ville les menus
la la coutellerie l'argenterie la
cristallerie tout ce qu'il faut pour
dîner dieu créa tout ça et qu'il ya
écrit à la commune 10 salon profs les
alors les les
les petites intrigues les remontrances
les bisbilles le snobisme et largo le
troisième jour dieu a créé à le tango du
parti dans le quatrième jour dieu créa
les automobiles carrément les concours
hippiques que les coûts rallongeant
l'île de puteaux
alors les vernissages les conférences vu
des choses un peu plus lauch les maisons
à double sortie les maisons de
retrouvailles de rendez-vous les maisons
louche il crée à romont une crise et
gris le flirt le show king le shopping
et le shooting l'adultère le dieu
rangement l'impudeur
il grille à la trahison le mensonge la
forfanterie et les pratiques religieuses
le cinquième jour degrés à la femme
l'homme et le poisson est le sixième
jour et créa les mondanités et le petit
écho de la mode est le 7e jour satisfait
de la grande oeuvre qu'il venait
d'accomplir dieu ça rosa mais alors
problèmes d'yeux propose et l'homme
dispose
hélas il s'aperçut bientôt qu'il était
la première victime du monde qu'il veut
d'être créée en effet à peine avait-il
enfiler sa robe de chambre qu'il l'est
ses pantoufles et sa jolie culotte de
ciel à peine était-il affaissé sur son
divan - le tour hambourg et nuages il
reçu par téléphone une invitation à
dîner le soir même en toute simplicité
quoi rocking histoire de faire un break
et l'at il s'aperçut que même à sebring
heures il ne pourrait pas faire le mort
puisqu'il était immortel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]